that gets me going that's that first
step that well begun is the job have
done hi there steve kaufman today i want
to talk about how to find the time to
learn languages or should i say how to
make the time to learn languages
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you're listening on apple podcast or
somewhere else please leave a review so
one of the most common excuses i hear
from people
who profess to want to learn languages
is that they simply don't have the time
that's right up there with
you know you have a talent for like
talking to me you have a talent for
languages i don't i can't learn
languages which normally refers back to
their experience at school where in fact
they didn't learn like most kids
at least in canada
but the other one is i don't have the
time people say that i don't have the
time so people seem to have time for
lots of activities
perfectly valid like meeting with their
friends and
watching tv or going hiking or
bicycling or whatever they like to do
but for whatever reason they can't find
the time to learn languages
typically what that means is i have
other activities that i prefer to do i
have other activities that are more
valuable to me than learning languages
which is fine not everybody has to learn
languages but
how then because we have busy lives our
professional or working lives our other
activities our social activities so how
do you create time find time make time
for learning languages
to me
the secret for me is
listening listening is the easiest thing
to do
i can listen first thing in the morning
i can listen in the car i can listen
wherever i am
and the listening is the trigger
and
in many languages and i think it goes
back to aristotle
who many languages sort of say you know
the first step is the most important
step the beginning is the job what well
begun is the job half done
uh chairman mao said the 10 000 lee
march began with with one step the main
thing is to get started and it's so easy
to just listen and then that triggers
the rest of it but you have to know how
to do it so first of all
make sure you equip yourself okay so in
my case
i listen from a number of devices
i can listen on my ipad
so this is normally where i work you
know on link but i can put it on my
stepper now not everyone has a stepper
at home obviously but i can have this
open
in the background in the morning when i
do my exercises using this
um program that i'm on which is on my
iphone i have my ipad open and i'm
listening to my
whatever it is persian arabic and so
forth so i use my ipad but at the other
end of the spectrum
if i go running jogging in the park
i take my
um
ipod
i should have brought this little device
i have that attaches to my arm so that i
just have my ipod here
it's light this is why i use it it's
lighter i could take my phone which i'm
using to record this video
but of course it's much bigger and
heavier so this is ideal for that okay
and this you know i have to load up
ahead of time so i have to make sure i
use the wi-fi at home to get whatever
content i want to listen to onto my ipad
so listening devices
also with both the
ipod and well on all three of them i can
subscribe to podcasts
um
i can
import audio and put it into my
apple music it used to be called itunes
so that i can accumulate all this stuff
to listen to now so far as listening
of course i have airpods which are in
many ways the best because they they
seem to be better at syncing and
connecting to these various devices
however
if i'm let's say i'm out cross country
skiing i certainly don't want to drop an
ipod in the snow
uh if i go down to the park and i run
and then i might do some
you know burpees or other things where
my head's moving around i i could again
drop my ipod so whenever i'm doing
something that's more active
i've also invested into these i think
they're called power
bumps or something like that
uh where here you know it's kind of it's
like that little kid with his mittens
tied to his sleeves i'm not going to
lose these so i use these power beats
maybe they're called
and more recently i discovered that
there's these guys because sometimes i
get tired
of having
something stuck in my ear so these are
called open ear
and so i also use these and it's a
relief not to have something stuck in
your ear the whole time so i have
invested a little money
in these listing devices because i spend
so much of my time listening listening
triggers it
listening triggers it because i listen
and i don't understand so then i have to
go through it
link
okay
and read it
and so that gets me going that's that
first step that well begun is the job
have done half done it's so easy for me
i get up in the morning i just put the
audio on and i do my morning exercises
which is also a good thing to get into
the habit of doing
and then uh little parts that i didn't
quite understand i can go back in and
and look up the words so
the first step is to
get used to listening and if i'm in the
car for example typically i'll have my
iphone and it'll be coming through the
bluetooth speaker in my car so i use
different cell between the ipad i don't
take my ipad in the car and i don't take
the ipod in the car i take my iphone in
the car so you develop these habits
the ways in which that you can always
have your listening handy now the other
part of listening is to find things to
listen to
and there i do a lot of listening to the
mini stories i mentioned them before
there's a lot of repetition i find that
it's it's good exercise i can i listen
to them now for the 30th or 40th time it
doesn't matter i always notice something
that's kind of my my training that's the
equivalent of my exercise in the morning
but i also need to find interesting
things now
you know i spent a lot of time looking
for content especially in arabic and
persian
we are trying in link to make it easier
for people to find things of interest at
their level but sometimes you have to
ask i saw a tweet the other day someone
said does anyone know of a good
intermediate level french podcast so i
immediately replied i said there's
francaio tautique and there's inner
french that i that immediately come to
mind so i answered so right away this
person can go there
find these podcasts which can be
imported in the link by the way but
there's a whole community of people who
can help each other find content of
interest so
you know
and this the great thing about listening
and why why listening
kind of helps you find the time is i i
it's more difficult to find the time to
sit in front of a of a screen and and
read or or to watch movies or to look
words up or to do link that that's
dedicated time you have to that's more
difficult to find but the listening time
you make that and that triggers the
whole range of activities around
language learning and that can be done
first thing in the morning while doing
the dishes
um
you know while in the car and i'll find
that certain activities lend themselves
to certain types of content if i have to
concentrate a little bit on what i'm
doing then i prefer to hear the mini
stories because even if i don't
concentrate the whole time there's
always something that
i become aware of that i noticed that i
hadn't noticed before
uh on the other hand if i'm in the car
actually i find it
easier to listen to something of
interest so it's a bit like if you're
listening to the radio and they're
giving you the traffic report or
something you can actually listen to
something where they there there is some
you know significance to what you're
listening to and at the same time drive
a little more difficult to do that
if i'm say working out in the morning
for example and i'm concentrating on
whatever i'm doing
then i prefer to have the many stories
going in the background
so i think everyone needs to develop a
program for themselves
but i just wanted to point out that that
to find the time to make the time to
learn languages listening is the easiest
is the easiest activity and you need to
build a range of sort of
circumstances around
what devices you use to play whatever
you're listening to
where you find the stuff you're going to
listen to varying the sort of repetitive
simple stuff with
more interesting new stuff uh different
you know ear phones that you can use for
different circumstances and you know put
yourself in a situation where you can
easily listen anytime you want to or
feel the urge or even if you don't feel
the urge so that you make that first
step that eventually will lead you to
putting in the time necessary to achieve
success in language learning so with
that i'll leave you with a few videos
that kind of
relate to this theme
thank you for listening bye for now